high profile case of plagiarism shocks
the machine learning world tesla has an
ai day extravaganza and all of stanford
writes a single paper welcome to ml news
stop before the rest of the video this
video is sponsored by weights and biases
weights and biases builds developer
tools for machine learning for
researchers for practitioners for
juniors for seniors whatever your
favorite flavor of yogurt is they don't
care they build products for you except
cherry who likes cherry
today i want to talk to you about a
feature called artifacts so artifacts
essentially are files in the cloud but
you're probably going to use them mostly
for two things data and models both of
these things are notoriously tricky to
work with data set is too large to check
into git we need to keep it up to date
we may have different versions of it and
models even more we want to save the
outputs of our runs into models that we
can then use later maybe introspect and
these things are also versioned and we
want to depend on them so when i did
this i had to save the model to some
special folder and then i had to go grab
it from that folder put it on all the
machines in a correct folder and then
reference that folder from all my
scripts that would then consume this
model with artifacts this gets a lot
easier so we first uploaded the original
data set to an artifact now we're going
to consume that artifact split the data
into train validation and test data and
then emit those things as artifacts so
if there is a new version of the raw
data available i can simply run the same
script depending on the same thing and
it will create new versions of the train
validation and test data you can make
this arbitrarily complex but i hope you
can see the point here the same goes for
models if your run outputs and saves
some kind of a model you can log that as
an artifact and from then on you can
consume that model in all subsequent
runs here's one of my models it's a cnn
you can see it's already version 116 of
that model but you can see all i have to
do to use this model in any code in any
script in the future i simply call the
download method on the artifact and it
will be available locally and as i told
you you can do this with any file but
since this is a model of a deep learning
framework weights and biases understands
it and gives me a neat viewer where i
can actually introspect the model and
look at the shapes and even at the
weights of my cnn so i think this is
incredibly powerful these things quickly
get complicated with versions and
scripts building upon other scripts and
the artifact framework really helps you
to make sense of all of it there's even
the possibility that the data stays in
specific private buckets with access
controls so not everyone in your team
has access to all of the data of course
artifacts are only one of the features
of weights and biases if you're
interested please check them out free
accounts are free academic accounts are
free enterprise accounts cost a bit and
that's it for this week's sponsor spot
thanks a lot to weights and biases let's
get into the video
[Music]
so on a lonely august evening i received
the following text on twitter paper a
plagiarized paper b and was accepted to
iccv now if you know anything about the
academic world especially the machine
learning world is that everyone copies
from everyone but i gave the papers a
look to confirm for myself so here is
paper a the first paper the
quote-unquote original paper called
momentum residual neural networks it's
by a bunch of researchers of ens cnrs
and google research the basic idea is to
bring some form of momentum to a
residual neural network since a resnet
resembles somewhat of an iterative
process the idea of momentum seems to be
applicable here the question is how
exactly you do that so here is a
visualization of their idea formulas are
here there's lots of mathematical
analysis there are experiments with
these concentric rings and what happens
to them and there is like a table
comparing it to previous approaches and
so on i'm looking at version one of the
paper for anyone who's following jumping
to the other paper and i'm not going to
reveal the name of the accused author
right here because i don't want to point
fingers or anything i simply want to
talk about the problem at hand so the
paper is called m revnet d reversible
neural networks with momentum that has
quite a similar idea in fact there is a
visualization of this flow there are
experiments with concentric rings being
deformed there is a neat little table
comparing it to previous approaches and
generally the structure and even the
sentences of entire passages appear to
be just reformulations of one another at
parts now i've looked further into this
and realized that the first paper open
sourced their code and the submission
history reveals that they've probably
tried to submit this to multiple
conferences and failed a bunch of times
before it got accepted so the paper was
out early hasn't been able to be
published code was out and then the
second paper appears now after looking
at this carefully i had the good
impression that the second paper simply
copied the first paper ran their code
with a bunch of different hyper
parameters maybe a different random seed
and essentially wrote the same paper
again possibly hoping that they could
get it through peer review before the
first paper or that it would just be
never be noticed at all so i first told
my discord community and contacted the
authors a bunch of people of my
community also contacted the authors and
got a hold of them at which point they
became aware and made the following
statement on twitter here habla says
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery simply posting the two links
they followed up with a piece by piece
comparison of the two papers essentially
laying out a case of plagiarism now at
this point twitter read it and the
different forums sprung into action
looked into this not only this but also
other papers previous papers by the same
author and dug up some worrisome conduct
but not only the western world but also
the chinese world now without revealing
too much the author in question happens
to be studying at a chinese university
and working for chinese companies so the
chinese world sprung into action
comparing papers by this author and
previous works and generally revealing
this sort of approach to research where
you take a paper and you do the
visualizations in what is often actually
a better way but nevertheless it's a
copy now besides the first paper there's
a strong case for also a second paper
being plagiarized but that case is
already very much more difficult so
people have pointed out things like
similarities and formulas similarities
in the used signal pattern in the
visualizations and so on in response to
this the co-authors of that first author
as well as the supervisors quickly
distanced themselves from the author
saying they didn't know they weren't
careful enough when looking at their
work they weren't that involved and the
first author responded by taking their
personal home page offline though you
can still access it via the internet
archive and retracting the paper from
archive with a comment given idea
overlapped with existing work yet by the
rules of archive a retracted paper is
still visible if you simply go to v1 of
the paper you can see the original
version the first author then went on
social media and issued a somewhat
apology saying that he made serious
omissions by this and that he conducted
the literature review for the paper
before the other paper was out and
didn't notice at the time of publication
that the ideas overlap in general he
tried to give an account of why the two
papers are so similar and how this came
about by just chants people having the
same kinds of ideas and so on now safe
to say this usually flies most cases of
academic plagiarism especially in
machine learning are never ever caught
or even pursued because you can always
make the case well it's a similar idea
and so on and there are a bit different
and whatnot in this case though the case
was so clear that i think the pressure
was overwhelming and the author edited
the post to essentially say that they
have plagiarized the two papers in
question they apologize they will stop
doing it they will learn from it and so
on needless to say this has generated a
giant amount of discussion as i said the
twitter post by pierre habla became very
widely spread reddit was on fire chinese
social media talked about this at length
i was in general impressed with the
amount of work that people put into
analyzing similarities between papers
however the best comment goes to a
combination of this user right here i
don't know who it is and google
translate it starts with after eating
melon for a few days you have already
said a lot about this matter
i'm this is so cool this is my this is
my new go-to saying i guess it's
probably some sort of a way to say after
thinking about it for a few days or
something like this and it's a
colloquial expression but this is gonna
become my new go-to sentence after
eating melon for a few days i've decided
excellent excellent i love it in
addition to that other people have come
out with various stories of plagiarism
for example shah huasan about code and
papers that he reportedly only submitted
to blind review yet other papers have
appeared that essentially are a copy of
his work which is even more shocking
it's not simply a person going on
archive and pulling down publicly
available information not citing it but
essentially abusing their position as a
anonymous peer reviewer now as i said
the amount of things happening like this
is uncountable most of it will never
ever get out or be done anything about
it the authors of the second paper here
have retracted it from iccv iccv
has already confirmed that this paper
will not be published at iccv and asked
everyone to not call it the iccv paper
which is why i dubbed it the paper
formerly known as the iccb paper if you
get this reference you're old so is this
the end of the story i don't know as i
said plagiarism is still widespread most
of it goes undetected and even from this
particular author it's very specific
that he apologized for plagiarizing
these two papers people have pointed out
similarities in other works and so on
and stemming from the fact that he first
tried to simply go silent then deny and
now admitting to these two papers and
combined with the fact that this author
has had like a record number of papers
in very short amount of time it could be
that this is simply a case of someone
who let themselves be inspired by
concurrent work a few times before and
seeing how successful this is and not
getting caught was getting more and more
and more blunt in the plagiarism as time
progressed i can't state that for sure i
don't know no one will ever be able to
prove anything like this so we'll just
have to live with the fact that it is
what it is it goes on pretty much
everywhere i've personally witnessed
quite a number of cases of people
borrowing each other's ideas and even
code and what are you gonna do
nothing needless to say this isn't a
case that we can solve easily with
simple plagiarism checkers which usually
check for some sort of engram overlap
and even if we have a sophisticated one
it's not gonna help as soon as people
know that it exists they're gonna game
it so we'll have to live with this for
the foreseeable future
there's a new paper called on the
opportunities and risks of foundation
models by everybody at stanford every
person has say in this
there are
many authors to this paper and it's sort
of a position paper on what they call
foundation models now a few things what
it actually is is mostly a literature
review on what you might ask well
foundation models foundation models is
these papers framing of models that are
kind of large and pre-trained on large
data and transfer learn than essentially
think bird gpt3 clip which they also
state in the text they say a foundation
model is any model that is trained on
broad data at scale and can be adapted
to a wide range of downstream tasks now
i have multiple problems with this 200
page monstrosity right here the first
one is with authorship itself how do so
many people work together on a single
paper the answer is they don't two
people were sort of the integrators and
i guess the writers of the introduction
and so on and then the individual
section of the papers were each authored
by a subgroup of people these
sub-sections are even labeled with the
individual authors and even contain
things like joint first authorship of
that subsection now in general i'll say
hey it's a free world do whatever you
like but this seems to be a little bit
of a gaming of the citation system in
academia citations aren't weighted by
number of authors or how much you
contributed to anything if your name's
on there you'll get a citation and this
paper ironically might serve as sort of
a foundation to be cited from many many
different other papers now you ask
yourself the question if someone wrote
the section about adaptation of
foundational models should they really
get a citation when someone is citing
the section on misuse authored by a
completely different set of authors my
personal opinion is no this isn't a
paper this is a collection of papers
like a compendium a book something like
this so it seems to be appropriate that
when we cite this work we cite the
individual section of the work along
with only the authors that wrote these
individual sections now another problem
that i and also other people have right
here is that it's not really a new thing
per se essentially these people simply
rebrand large pre-trained models as
foundation models it's a very shaky
definition and it seems like it's just
kind of a grab of a particular field or
subfield for this particular group of
people rather than simply contributing
to the research landscape as a
participant there's a serious disconnect
between the definition that they give
for foundation models a foundation model
is any model that is trained on broad
data at scale and can be adapted to a
wide range of downstream tasks and what
they actually talk about now usually in
technical subjects we do things such as
we put up a definition of something and
then we derive our conclusions our
experiments our hypotheses and so on
from that definition however this paper
does something completely different
essentially none of the opportunities
and risks they mention here are
consequences of this definition for
example a section on loss in
accessibility why if foundation models
are simply these models that can be
adapted to things how does that
necessitate loss in accessibility how
does this necessarily impact the
environment i can see the large language
models we have today do that but how do
you derive this from the definition like
you can't and how does the definition
justify 200 pages essentially if you
amend the definition of foundation
models to say something like there are
efforts that cost a lot of money and
then a lot of other things are built
upon these efforts and that means
anything that's built on top of it
inherent all the properties including
all the problems all the design
decisions and so on all the properties
of these intermediate efforts and since
it's costly to produce them it's also
costly to change them up there are
opportunity costs there are dangers of
centralization of these things and that
that's about it and that's with the
extended definition now if you think
about the definition what comes to mind
for me is something like a resnet50 a
pre-trained resnet50 on imagenet is used
throughout the world it's used in so
many applications a lot of people build
on it yet the number of people that
actually fine tune gpt3 outside of
openai is zero the number of actual
products that are built on in context
learning is very limited so if gpt3
counts as a foundation model certainly
resonant 50 does after all it is a model
trained on broad data at scale well here
is the paper on the imagenet dataset
large scale ergo
it's large scale and diversity ergo
broad range they say collecting imagenet
is a challenging task so not exactly
cheap they describe the data collection
scheme and so on and let's not forget
the uh centrality and bias and data
quality question in the resin at 50
imagenet the dataset contains literal
pornographic material i've discussed
this on my videos previously so if
resnet50 doesn't count as a foundational
model then then i don't know how just
because it's a few years old and doesn't
cost as much as the models today it fits
every bit of the definition of a
foundation model yet resnet50 is
mentioned one time in this 200 page
document only to controls it to clip yet
it's pretty clear what they actually
mean gpt3
namely gpt3 is mentioned over and over
and over and over and over 65 times in
this entire document only to be topped
by
bert which is mentioned a whopping
174 times though sometimes it's like a
sub part of another word so rather than
deriving conclusions from the definition
the paper is actually a series of
anecdotes about some models that also
fit the definition yet to me that
doesn't justify the new term especially
if you go that far away from the
definition that's like me writing a
paper on the opportunities and risks of
groupian models which is any model
containing an abelian group and i write
200 pages about how bad gpt-3 is because
after all gpt3 surely contains an
abelian group somewhere in there now
with all the grumpiness i know it can
get a bit much the paper is actually a
great literature review on models such
as gpt3 dali clip in general the current
models that are trained on large-scale
data and might not be entirely
accessible to everyone i'm not trying to
deny that there are dangers to that but
let's keep in mind that for example
gpt-2 was also considered incredibly
expensive and non-accessible and if you
remember even too dangerous to release
at the point of release yet these
dangers haven't actually materialized
and as far as centralization of models
go and choke points i'm pretty sure it
has happened previously in the machine
learning world that pretty much everyone
used the same couple of two or three
really well working algorithms no can't
think of any none of them well okay
let's continue so the community will
have to decide if they accept this new
term foundation models or if we just
call gpt-3 and bert by their names
[Music]
okay next news the neural hash story
continues there are various projects in
order to create collisions or run neural
hash by itself there's even one in the
browser i also have one if you want
watch the video so also we have now
reports that imagenet contains naturally
occurring hash collisions by roboflow
here you can search imagenet for uh
things that elucidate the same neural
hash apple has responded by saying that
there's another server-side check if you
prevent wrong collisions and so on but
safe to say this neural hash system
isn't the most effective you can evade
it easily you might be able to force
collisions yet still we have a report
from kron 4 that a bay area doctor was
found with 2 000 images and videos of
child pornography we don't know exactly
if this is already a result of this
system if it is you know good job it
works as intended that makes me happy
that it worked here it still does make
me more comfortable with the privacy
implication of neural hash in general
next news facebook ai research releases
a new paper called control strategies
for physically simulated characters
performing two player competitive sports
this is a reinforcement learning
framework for control applications where
you have mostly humanoids doing sports
but essentially the core parameters here
are that there are a lot of degrees of
freedom in some sort of a two-player
game in a continuous environment i just
love that the algorithm seems to come up
with actual cool strategies and good
control policies it's not so easy for
these things to balance themselves in
the first place and then to fight a
boxing match where everyone tries to
punch the other one to the ground is
quite difficult so you can see the
difference between this new framework
and sort of a comparison framework i
argue that the baseline though is the
more interesting one certainly oh no
if you're interested in control and two
player games
check it out
[Music]
tesla had its ai day this was a big
presentation where they talked about all
their advancements into ai i don't know
if i should make an entire reaction
video to that i think i will in the
meantime lex friedman has made an
excellent overview over the most
important things that happened there i
highly recommend you go check that out
and we have we have we have to talk
about the tesla bot so the idea here is
that all these technologies tesla's
developing for the car can also be
deployed in a more general way in a
humanoid robot to do manual labor so
this is from an article in ieee spectrum
this is the slide that tesla had up
displaying the tesla bot now besides the
applications of eliminates dangerous
repetitive and boring tasks it's also
supposed to be friendly gotta you gotta
you gotta love elon musk now needless to
say this is probably
over promised both in whether or not
that's doable at all with current or
near future technology to the timeline
they give which is i think something
like a year or so is probably not going
to happen as advertised but i come to
think that musk sometimes does things
just to provoke exactly the reactions
that we're getting elon musk has no idea
what he's doing with tesla pot humanoid
robots are way harder than musk seems to
think sometimes i wonder if he's like
what if i just tell them i'm gonna build
a robot in a year also the way he
introduced the robot is first of course
it's just a mock-up slide but then he
actually brought a human in a robot suit
up on stage
and the human starts acting robotic but
then of course increasingly gets less
robotish
and you just see elon smile back there
this was totally like you can imagine
him sitting
planning this out is like what if
we like get a human
and then
just
so the world decides whether this is
funny or not i think it's hilarious this
is 100 hilarious
now as far as competitors go george hotz
revealed the comma 3 which other than
tesla self-driving approaches is a thing
that you can put into a lot of different
cars essentially one mounted unit with
cameras on it that is also supposed to
do driving assistance and i think
something like fully self-driving in the
near future there's also a big long
presentation about the specs of the
command 3 the problems with self-driving
with navigation in general with covering
all of the edge cases and other than
tesla comma takes an open source
approach where it actively wants the
community of developers to help
developing the product further so if you
are interested in that the comma 3 dev
kit is available to order
next news crn writes intel says it's
winding down realsense camera business
so intel was developing cameras sensors
and so on for computer vision
application now it's saying it's
shutting that down to focus on its core
business mid of a loss if you had one of
these or were planning on getting one of
these we've seen companies in the past
saying they are going to focus on their
core business and it's not really clear
what it means for some companies it
means they are on the edge of bankruptcy
while for others it means they just want
to make even more cash needless to say
if you're looking into sensors and
vision hardware intel is no longer the
place to do so but ibm might be pr
newswire writes ibm unveils on-chip
accelerated artificial intelligence
processor okay this is not a camera or a
sensor i just thought it was a great
segue into the next segment but ibm
unveiled the telum processor which
essentially has an ai accelerator on
chip so a matrix multiplier their idea
is to bring the compute to where the
data is and so on but it's good to see a
bit of competition in the market for
accelerator chips
okay kaggle has a new competition up
called lux ai this is essentially a
two-player game where you control units
and have to collect as much light
sources as possible to survive the night
so if you're interested in game playing
agents give the lox ai challenge a try
or if you are interested in game playing
agents in very large world together with
lots of other agents look into ai
crowd's neural mmo challenge here you
deploy an agent into a world with not
just one other player but many other
players over longer periods of time the
goal is to collect resources and at the
same time keep others from collecting
their resources it's very cool to see
these kinds of challenges you don't have
to use reinforcement learning or
anything you can just script your bot if
you want to but it's usually cool to see
which approaches win at the end in these
very open world challenges very cool
give it a try
okay at this point i want to shout out
to dribnet who has been making a step
into a bit of a different direction
using the clip model and its image
generation capabilities going into pixel
art and this looks very very cool so
he's been generating various skylines
and going through the abc with various
words zygote and zoo there's wellington
a yacht and a yakuza x-ray in xenomorph
i love the idea that going to pixel art
essentially blurs the line between human
created and machine created even more a
lot of these pictures look absolutely
fantastic so this can be potentially
used to just
create funny pictures but also can be
combined for example to create video
game assets and various other things
where pixel art is generally used
okay following up a bit on the
plagiarism issue the reinforcement
learning subreddit saw a big post saying
that multi-agent reinforcement learning
top conference papers are ridiculous
essentially alleging that the entire
field has a problem with unfair
experimental tricks or cheating
essentially what you want to do is just
implement really crappy bass lines and
then have your model be bigger more
powerful take a longer time have more
information and do a better hyper
parameter search essentially what we're
used to from the entire field of machine
learning but the subfield of multi-agent
reinforcement learning because it's
super noisy and the experiments are
mostly not standardized apparently has a
particularly large problem with this so
there are people voicing in saying
they've published in these fields and
this is absolutely true mostly also that
papers with solid experiments aren't
getting published because i guess
they're not as flashy as the paper with
the tricked experiments needless to say
another bit of evidence that you
shouldn't take the experimental results
or any individual paper statements at
face value
benzynga writes elon musk lex friedman
see language evolving with help of
artificial intelligence wow this sounds
like a thing that they interview elon
musk that they analyze years of work and
integrated anything like this no no they
just they looked at they looked at two
tweets they looked at two tweets and
they made a news article about that all
right ai helps a lot of people tweeting
this right now tweeting this right now i
want a news article tomorrow you hear
that tomorrow
all right now we come to our segment of
ai news questions which i answer
absolutely without any context or
reading the article here we go zitinet
writes can ai improve your pickup lines
wait actually i i need to right here's
what he comes up with
do you want to have a cup of coffee
wow you know i guess for most people
using pickup lines simply saying please
don't use pickup lines just ask them for
coffee is an improvement so the answer
is yes the enquirer asks what if the
simpsons were voiced by artificial
intelligence
i don't care as long as bart is still in
scientology all is good presenza asks
artificial intelligence or human
intelligence
i don't know
probably depends on the tasks you want
to solve analytics inside asks which
career should you choose data science
versus artificial intelligence
just learn the program you'll be fine
just learn the program the bbc asks is
a.i biased
yes the answer is yes but probably not
in the ways that the loudest people tell
you it's probably biased in a bit more
of a boring way and probably a bit less
in a oh my god this is terrible way
ricochet asks when will artificial
general intelligence actually arise to
this technology summit here i don't know
but neither do they design news asks how
smart can a machine get i don't know i
what's this question like seven smart a
machine can probably get seven smart
cool and forbes asks is artificial
intelligence contributing positively to
parenting let's check this out google
what to do if my baby turns blue if your
baby is turning blue calling 911 is very
appropriate thanks ai i guess the answer
is yes all right that was it for our
news questions if you see a news
question and want it answered without me
reading anything let me know
okay a few last shout outs if you're old
like me you remember the good old days
of blobby volley well here's a 3d
volleyball reinforcement learning
environment built with unity ml agents
check it out also in light ai releases
maze applied reinforcement learning for
real world problems it doesn't really
have anything to do with an actual maze
it is yet another rl framework but rl
frameworks are kind of like there are
many of them and most of them have
something wrong and something right and
if you haven't found any yet that fit
you maybe give this one a try
and lastly metaphor releases wanderer 2
a large language model that was trained
we searched through 2.5 million articles
that were posted on hacker news and yes
hacker news has a notoriably crappy
search function so uh thank you cool
this was it for this week's ml news i
thank you so much for checking in and
checking out weights and biases that
being said have great rest of the week
i'll see you next monday ciao
[Music]
you